[Musique]
bienvenue ravi de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui paris saclay tv prend la
clef des champs nous sommes à la ferme
de bulletins c'est l'une des nombreuses
entreprises agricoles que compte votre
territoire depuis près de huit ans le
plateau de saclay se transforme se
construit mais il ne faudrait pas
oublier qu'il est avant tout une rue
râle et pour préserver ce monde agricole
plusieurs actions ont été prises dont un
dispositif inédit en france la z paix
naf la zone de protection naturelle
agricole et forestière quelques chiffres
c'est 4115 hectares de protéger dont
près de 2470 consacrée exclusivement aux
activités agricoles
une charte d'engagement vient d'être
signé et parmi ceux qui s'engagent
il y à l'état évidemment mais il ya
aussi la société civile
nous avons rencontré thomas joly c'est
le président de l'association terre est
cité cette volonté de préserver la
nature de concilier batié campagne elle
a été prise en compte dès le début du
projet le pea paris saclay a fait appel
à un paysagiste
il s'appelle michel davy et il va nous
expliquer comment elle fait pour
concilier ces deux mondes
enfin notre agenda ce sera à la fin de
cette émission
[Musique]
c'est un dispositif inédit en france un
dispositif qui veut faire dialoguer le
rural et l'urbain la charte de la z pena
fly zone de protection naturelle
agricole et forestière vient d'être
signé l'état s'engage à pérenniser
plus de 2400 hectares sur le plateau de
saclay un plateau qui se transforme ce
mot dernier se construit mais qui veut
garder son identité agricole tout de
suite les explications de philippe
ventes de mal
directeur général de le paix à paris
saclay
[Musique]
aujourd'hui est une grande étape dans
l'histoire de cette zone de protection
naturelle agricole et forestière
killzone qui a été créée en 2010 et dont
le périmètre a été finalisée en 2013
c'est vraiment un atout essentiel
aujourd'hui ont signé une charte une
charte d'engagement de tous les
partenaires aussi bien l'état les
collectivités locales les acteurs pas
rationnel du monde agricole notamment en
agriculture mais aussi forestier donc
tous les partenaires se sont engagés
dans une démarche collective de
protection et l'animation de la zp et
n'affichant que c'est une démarche forte
le préfet l'a dit c'est ce n'est pas
figé on est là pour compléter si c'est
nécessaire et c'est donc on est vraiment
cette ville mk est ce un moment assez
fort parce que c'est le résultat d'un
travail collectif qui montrent que tous
les acteurs sont engagés dans la
protection de ce territoire là qui est
un atout formidable d'ailleurs que le
projet de paris saclay on est vraiment
dans cette dynamique la vie par ailleurs
il ya une autre dimension qu'on va
signer aujourd'hui avec la chambre
d'agriculture et monsieur le préfet clé
un protocole pour participer au
financement du programme d'action fait
que cette zone de protection naturelle
agricole forestière c'est un territoire
avec une charte d'engagement et une
protection à la non organisation mais il
ya aussi la volonté d'un programme
d'actions pour valoriser accompagner le
monde agricole accompagné les zones le
protéger dans une plus grande
valorisation et nous avons signé
aujourd'hui avec la chambre
d'agriculture et monsieur le préfet un
protocole qui fait que les gays les
financements que donc on était censé
faire en termes de coûts de compensation
agricole nous les fléchois et c'était la
volonté qu'on a essayé de pousser nous
les fréchon sur les actions agricoles du
programme d'action global
ce travail collectif et je me réjouis
qu'on avance favorablement dans ce
territoire où le monde agricole
d'ailleurs une
une dynamique très forte aussi bien
économique comme en termes d'innovation
qui utilisent rejoint parfaitement
l'objectif de ce territoire quels
territoires d'innovation de la france
vous l'aurez compris cette charte a
voulu rassembler tous les acteurs du
territoire et parmi ses partenaires il y
à terre est cité cette association veut
sanctuariser ces milliers d'hectares
elle veut aussi animer cette aide pénale
pour thomas jolly son président il faut
accompagner les exploitations agricoles
leur proposer des solutions des projets
il nous explique comment t'est réciter
est avant toute chose une association
assez étrange puisqu'elle est installé
sur deux départements sur trois
intercommunalités comprend vingt
communes et s'intéresse donc au plateau
de saclay et à ses vallées elle est
composée de quatre collèges ce qui ne
rend pas la vie très facile au président
parfois avec bien évidemment au coeur
les agriculteurs mais aussi les élus
locaux les associations et l'ensemble de
la société civile dans laquelle est
inclut les éléments de la recherche qui
sont fondamentales sur ce territoire
notre travail c'est de veiller à animer
en particulier la zp hénaff qui est cet
espace sanctuariser depuis 2010 avec
2300 hectares mais aussi de travailler à
rendre cet espace approprié par les gens
qui vivent ou par les gens qui y
travaillent
c'est essentiel pour sa protection
la z pena fait un élément extrêmement
important pour nous car cela sanctuary
notre territoire sur 2300 hectares ce
qui est important dans cette aide pena
il y à une charte qui régule les
activités car rien ne serait pire qu'un
espace complètement saoul vase clos avec
aucune possibilité de faire quoi que ce
soit
donc il faut bien animer les choses
cette charte doit permettre le
développement des activités agricoles et
de façon rémunératrice pour les
entreprises agricoles et les familles
qui travaillent mais en même temps
permettre toutes sortes d'activités
liées au monde agricole
[Musique]
il faut coupler cette charte avec le
programme d'action sur l'ensemble de la
z paix naf et faire se marier les deux
et travailler à faire en sorte que le
programme actions se mettent en oeuvre
parce que si rien ne se passe sur ce
territoire
on trouvera toujours de bons prétextes
pour dire qu' il est temps de passer à
une autre phase pour l'avenir de cet
espace
[Musique]
l'économie circulaire est un véritable
enjeu pour notre pays et nous voulons
apporter notre contribution à cette
problématique notamment à travers la
conception d'un living lab dans lequel
les matières organiques sont
essentielles produit par les
agriculteurs d'une part mais aussi tous
les restaurants de tous les
établissements qui se trouvent sur ce
territoire nous engageons aujourd'hui un
processus de réflexion pour analyser les
quantités de gisements la nature de ces
derniers leur capacité à être
transformés pour produire de l'énergie
ou des amendements pour les sols ça
c'est une chose qui est extrêmement
importante pour nous parallèlement à
cela nous travaillons sur les circuits
courts en favorisant l'émergence des
épis mais aussi faire en sorte que dans
les différents établissements
les rationnaires puissent manger des
produits locaux avec le minimum
d'intermédiaire et si possible en
sollicitant les agriculteurs pour qu'ils
puissent se transformer évolué et
pourquoi pas proposer des produits bio
c'est un des objectifs que nous pouvons
partager avec les agriculteurs et sur ce
territoire
c'est là où il ya eu le plus grand
nombre de buts à sion en termes de
nombre d'hectares par rapport à la
région ile de france qui se sont
transformés en espaces agricoles
biologiques
cette volonté de faire coexister monde
rural et urbain elle existe depuis le
début de l'aménagement de paris saclay
depuis 2010 l'établissement public
d'aménagement parle saclay ses forces
avec l'appui de l'urbanisme et
paysagiste michel desvigne de proposer
un projet qui permette de concilier le
développement d'un grand campus urbain
et le maintien de l'environnement
naturel et agricole du plateau de saclay
[Musique]
paris est ici nous sommes à 15 km de la
capitale sur l'opération d'intérêt
national paris saclay qui s'étend sur
sept mille 700 hectares le coeur a été
sanctuarisée par une zone de protection
naturelle agricole et forestière qui
s'étend sur plus de 2300 hectares et les
franges sont en cours d'aménagement et
se développe sur des quartiers existants
qui accueille 10 % de la recherche
française
nous devons simultanément réfléchir à
des échelles distinctes à celle du
territoire de l'établissement public
donc sur environ 30 kilomètres
simultanément aussi à l'échelle du sud
du plateau où sont regroupés l'essentiel
des campus aujourd'hui donc sur environ
7 km puis enfin nous devons aussi
imaginer la mise en oeuvre des espaces
publics pour l'un des quartiers pour
environ 3 km
c'est une échelle inédite de projet nous
a semblé dès le début un très important
de nous faire accompagner par une équipe
de maîtrise d'oeuvre urbaine et
paysagère
là où d'habitude on ne fait que de la
planification réglementaire parce que
pour nous la question du paysage était
la clé d'entrée du projet nous nous
sommes tous référé un exemple
relativement récent tout début du 20e
siècle
l'expansion du campus georgetown près de
washington s'est faite justement avec un
paysagiste comme leader de cette équipe
de mise en oeuvre
bien sûr il y avait beaucoup de prêts
existence à saclay notamment et campus
importants souvent de l'ordre de 200
hectares comme le ceva au fond ce qui
apparaît très fort dans ce territoire
sur les cartes bien sûr mais aussi dans
le site ce sont ces coteaux boisés ses
coteaux boisés constituent des lignes
d'horizon depuis le plateau comme depuis
les vallées l'amplification de ses
présences boisé c'est l'élément physique
qui peut donner la cohérence à un
ensemble préexistant de lieux de
recherche qui sont dispersés la
géographie amplifiée est un élément de
cohérence qui opère aussi pour ce
cadrage de 7 km c'est la ligne d'horizon
c'est là doucement mais il est
nécessaire également pour ses sept
kilomètres d'avoir un système de parcs
ce que nous appelons des runes 10 hier
qui va donner la cohérence à tous les
cartes
cette maquette permet d'apprécier ce que
sera la lisière à terme donc la lisière
c'est l'espace de transition paysagère
entre les terrains agricoles d'une part
et les différents quartiers du campus
urbain
nous avons réussi à dégager environ 200
hectares sur sept kilomètres de long
avec l'ambition d'installer une chaîne
de park une chaîne d' espaces publics
qui relie tous les usages de ces campus
bien sûr et surtout avec l'ambition de
créer un paysage intermédiaires qui
assurent de meilleures transition entre
le bâti et la campagne
nous disposons de nombreuses vies il
s'agit de gérer les eaux de cet immense
quartier
il s'agit de localiser des mesures
compensatoires au fond d'eux l'idée
toute simple c'est de fabriquer un
paysage avec ses leviers de faire de ces
contraintes tellement de financement de
gestion de construction du paysage dont
nous avons besoin pour établir un
meilleur rapport entre les quartiers et
la campagne donc la lisière agricole
s'organise
naturellement avec le parcellaire
existants et c'est dans ces traces que
nous installons les fossés les nous les
bassins certaines dépressions qui
permettent en effet d'une part de
stocker l'eau mais également d'installer
toute une série de zones humides
il fait de s'inscrire dans un paysage
extraordinaire c'est la volonté à un peu
innovante de méthodologique de pouvoir
intégrer cette dimension de lien entre
la ville et son environnement entre la
ville et le paysage avoisinants qui très
riche du travail en maintenant depuis
près de dix ans avec michel desvigne ce
temps long du projet nous a permis de
mûrir une solution qui nous semble
apporter une réponse à une problématique
essentielle aujourd'hui qui est la
transition entre les villes et
l'agriculture
[Musique]
notre agenda à présent on commence
l'année 2019 avec le comité de suivi des
chantiers de le paix à paris saclay
c'est le 8 janvier à 17 heures à la
résidence clef paris saclay c'est à
palaiseau nos rendez vous culturel à
présent avec un 1er janvier en musique
ne ratez pas les trois concerts du
nouvel an organisée par la communauté
d'agglomération paris saclay c'est de la
musique classique c'est gratuit ces
concerts auront lieu sur trois communes
à l'opéra de massy à 11 heures au
théâtre de longjumeau à 15 heures et à
l'espace jacques-brel de
villebon-sur-yvette l'a7 à 18 heures la
programmation sera révélé à la dernière
minute
enfin un petit bijou théâtral signé de
tchekhov la cerisaie c'est les 19 et 20
janvier au théâtre de saint quentin en
yvelines
et voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi je vous
souhaite d'excellentes fêtes de fin
d'année je vous retrouve très vite en
2019 pour un nouveau numéro de paris
saclay tv d'ici là vous pouvez être
informés grâce à notre site peu aps
point fr grâce à tv 78 moi je vous dis à
très bientôt je suis allé voir ce qui se
passe au marché de la ferme chaos
[Musique]